[Musique]
thouars et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici l les titres et des équipes du
monde entier des pompiers de toute la
france le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines sera le théâtre dans
quelques jours d'un concours
d'extraction pour les pompiers à un
concours aux visées pédagogiques
auxquels se prépare à la caserne de
montigny le bretonneux
il n'aura tenu qu'un mois le projet de
communes nouvelles entre coignard et
maurepas a été abandonné il ya quelques
jours sous la pression notamment de
l'opposition à coignères et des
habitants serge pradines ancien
directeur général des services de quymja
les opposants au projet sera notre
invité dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons notamment sur les nouveautés
annoncées pour la rentrée sur le réseau
stibus avec notamment le renfort de
certaines lignes
le soir et le week-end en 2016 les
sapeurs pompiers de france sont
intervenus auprès de 3,8 millions de
personnes en situation d'urgence des
hommes et des femmes qui arbore une
condition physique irréprochable et
s'entraîne continuent quotidiennement
sur des situations proches de la réalité
à montigny le bretonneux par exemple 14
pompiers s'exerce en ce moment à la
désincarcération et aux secours
d'urgence en vue des challenges
nationaux à la fin du mois organisé à
saint quentin en yvelines pour
l'événement des hommes du feu de
l'étranger de toute la france sont
attendus sur place reportage de camille
lambert et marion ptac
extraction d'une victime accidenté les
pompiers maîtrisent la situation les
gestes sont précis la communication
calme tout cela est un exercice depuis
six mois 14 compile vinoy s'entraîne une
fois par semaine sur la prise en charge
des victimes de la route autour de
différents scénarios allez les gars on
peut avoir donc deux ou trois véhicules
impliqués dans l'accident on peut
également avoir des glissières de
sécurité qui nous servent d'obstacles
des arbres des poteaux téléphoniques
ça permet d'agrémenter les scénarios et
d'avoir toujours des choses à faire
plus complexe et réfléchir à des prises
en charge
vraiment spécifique les exercices
doivent être réalisés en un temps
imparti 10 ou 30 minutes en fonction du
nombre de victimes afin d'assurer le bon
déroulement de la mission un chef
d'equipe chapeau de ses hommes sur le
scénario du jour les difficultés étaient
multiples c'est surtout la voiture qui
est en équilibre sur le capot avant
d'autres voitures paquet tombes des
hacker faux paquets tombe sur le
personnel faut pas qu'elle tombe sur la
victime qui est à l'intérieur et il faut
pas qu'il ya sur accident générés par le
scénario mis en place après chaque
exercice les sapeurs-pompiers débrief
nico il rentre et des échanges
constructifs pour se rendre compte des
erreurs ou salué l'intervention
on a sorti la victime en moins de dix
minutes et l'objectif c'était dix
minutes on a sorti la victime en moins
de dix minutes en respectant les
consignes de sécurité en mettant en
application le matériel et
et tout le monde a bien oeuvré c'est
bien mais on va dire la pression pour ça
se passe dans de bonnes conditions
les hommes du feu pourront se mesurer à
d'autres pompiers français et
internationaux du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome national de saint quentin lors
du challenge nationaux sapeurs-pompiers
des compétitions de désincarcération et
de secours d'urgence aux personnes
seront organisées durant ces trois jours
en bref dans l'actualité également la
grève des cheminots reprend dimanche et
lundi sur les lignes n ai eu du
transilien ou encore le rer c des
perturbations sont donc à prévoir pour
vous rendre ou partir de saint quentin
en yvelines pour connaître la
circulation de vos lignes et d'éventuels
itinéraires alternatifs consulter le
site transilien.com durée de vie
minimale pour le projet de rapprochement
entre les villes de maurepas et
coignières l'idée d'une commune nouvelle
dévoilée par les maires il ya tout juste
un mois vient d'être stoppé un abandon
du fait notamment des nombreuses
oppositions à coignières élus et
habitants dénoncer pêle-mêle le manque
de concertation une perte d'identité
pour la commune selon eux serge pradines
est notre invité
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir la parole
au collectif citoyen contre le projet de
fusion
voilà c'est ce que j'allais dire vous
êtes membre du collectif citoyen de
coignières aussi ancien directeur
général des services c'est important de
le préciser
vous connaissez bien tous les sujets
locaux est ce que c'est une surprise
pour vous d'apprendre l'abandon du
projet seulement un mois après
avoir été dévoilé à la presse absolument
pas la méthode qui a été utilisée c'est
à dire convoqué les élus le 9 avril et
le personnel le matin sans objet sans
donner le motif sans aucune élément
particulier et annoncer le projet de
fusion avec maurepas
ça a été pris en plein vol en plein choc
en tout cas la méthode n'a pas été
correct par rapport à une démocratie
participative tel qu'on nous le
défendrons il ya un référendum mais
peut-être pas l'abandon c'est une c'est
une bonne surprise pour vous quand même
disons qu'il ya là qu'ils étaient pour
le référendum d'autres pour le retrait
mais c'est vrai que à partir du moment
où les élus on n'a qu'à une commune de 4
400 habitants et les élus
nous ce qu'on leur reproche quand je
m'exprime je mets ce que nous venons de
l'ensemble des forces vives de ce
collectif qui composaient aussi d'élus
qui ont quitté de la majorité au mois de
septembre on en a trois indépendants des
ripailles eux que l'ancien maire qui
également de l'opposition et tenir pour
tous dirigés par guy fischer voilà ça
c'est les élus qui sont au sein du
collectif et ensuite on a des
associations des personnalités un peu
comme moi on a même le ce qui était
surprenant et qui a été vraiment très
intéressant l'ensemble des citoyens qui
sont dans la résidence des acacias
pourquoi selon vous le
le maire remplaçant pour l'occasion
david pelletier qui a pris la succession
pour dans quelques temps de jean pierre
se baisse pour maladie at il décidé en
concertation sûrement avec sa majorité
de retirer la loge le projet quelques
quelques élus de la minute de la
majorité qui sont 114 et l'ue sur 27
conseillers municipaux ont été
influencés par le la population et puis
peut-être ils avaient leur propre état
d'âme en tout cas on n'avait pas la
communication de leur pensée on avait au
moins trois un petit noyau dur qui
n'étaient pas d'accord sur le projet et
puis son noyau dur s'est transformée
aujourd'hui en a 8 9 conseillers
municipaux de la majorité sur 14 qui ne
sont pas pour le projet donc du coup
comme en plus j'en percevais ce que
c'est une grave erreur qu'il a fait
c'est à dire en affaires le projet mais
uniquement avec les votes des conseils
municipaux comme la loi notre le permet
cédric lalonde notre si lily à fusion il
y à exonération donc rares baisses de
dotations de l'état pendant trois ans et
encouragé par les sanglots la loi
encourage les fusions insulte aux nîmois
qui est adapté pour les communes rurales
faut savoir qu'avant france 87% de le
commune au moins de 2000 habitants et
sur la communauté européenne sur les 28
états il ya 40% des communes qui se
concentraient en france donc on comprend
qu'on veut mais pas pour des communes
comme coignières dont usain etc où il ya
une vie une vitalité une richesse
incroyable ou coignières c'est une
visite qui fait bon vivre
reprenez vous vous pensez que l'absence
du maire de
du maire jean-pierre sevestre pour des
raisons de santé a joué aussi en faveur
de l'arrêt du projet c'est difficile
pour nous d'exprimer par rapport à un
argument de santé en tout cas il a eu le
temps lorsqu'il s'est arrêté de choisir
le quatrième adjoint
alors c'est pas légal vous savez que
lorsqu'un appel est illégal devrait
mettre le quatrième il fallait pas le
premier sur la plénitude de ses
fonctions c'était légal voilà ensuite il
ya une suppléance une première adjointe
alors sa famille le pen aujourd'hui la
jeune fille catherine mhadjou enfin sur
le plan juridique c'est déjà une ineptie
mais ensuite il a eu le temps de
désigner à 80 4 juin de préparer un peu
le ce qui allait se passer
et en plus il n'est même pas lui qui a
retiré le projet c'est dans une partie
qu'il a retiré avec cette majorité
bancal et qui et c'est ce qu'on reproche
c'est une majorité c'est une décision
des élus qui sont hors sol qui sont
complètement déconnectés des réalités
locales
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les arguments
avancés notamment le manque de moyens en
tout cas la baisse des moyens des
dotations de l'état
c'est un argument qu'on entend souvent
ici même sur glace de tv 78 de la part
des maires est ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui coignard n'a pas de
problèmes financiers que du coup ce
projet n'avait aucune aucun lieu d'être
je parlais ont connaissance de cause
poignard une santé financière saine des
finances équilibrées on a des marges de
manoeuvre c'est intéressante on a un
budget de l'ordre de 10 millions d'euros
et malgré tout parce qu'on a intégré la
communauté d'agglomération le 1er
janvier 2016
et ça faisait peur beaucoup mais on nous
avons comme une attribution de
compensation de 5 millions dont on
récupère 5 millions de la fiscalité
économique
on a tellement qui est un endettement
qui est très faible donc la situation au
fur et à mesure qu'ils ont la démarche
très intéressante filer beaucoup de
villes peut-être
j'aimerais mieux être adjoint des
finances mais six essais c'est évident
coignières a toujours été convoité
courtisé et l'histoire de coignières est
toujours été de dire non je veux rester
seul
autonome et c est ce que ça a du sens
finalement de vouloir rester seul
alors qu'on le voit bien vous le disiez
la loi encourage la fusion et que
finalement si on prend l'activité de
commercial de coignard il n'ya pas
uniquement les quoi ni rien qui viennent
ya aussi les mortuaciens il ya des gens
courtois
est ce que cette volonté parfois et
cette impression qui se dégage de ne pas
vouloir partager les rentrées
financières de la ville mais par un peu
mauvaise aussi pour elles sont
aujourd'hui ça vaut le coup mais demain
qui sait que la situation financière de
moyens sera toujours aussi elles sont
partagées et d'ailleurs depuis longtemps
puisque
on a toujours participé avec maurepas à
des projets intercommunaux le syndicat
d'assainissement la déchetterie qui sont
partis à saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui on est une police pury et
communales on avait le projet de centre
aquatique qui dresse le rapprochement
baril est toujours aujourd'hui on a 800
entreprises six hôtels une trentaine de
restaurants et j'en passe c'est une
commune extrêmement riche on à 5500
salariés sur la commune beaucoup plus
que nombre d'habitants
imaginez cette vitalité cette richesse
on a trente quatre associations etc
comment peut-on supprimer avec une
fusion décidée sur le coin d'une table
par un élu qui n'a pas la légitimité
puisque la justice c'est monsieur pas
lieu qui a été élu en 2014 et pageant
personness qui a démissionné et monsieur
semestre a été élu par le conseil
municipal
dernière question pourquoi pour conclure
sur le sujet on est pris par le temps
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour ce
sujet d'un rapprochement avec un mort
par reviendra sur le devant de
l'actualité nous nous collectif on est
extrêmement méfiant et on va rester
vigilant on va se réunir dans les 15
jours et prendre des décisions sur
l'organisation éventuellement de cette
pérennité éventuel donc du collectif et
l'organisation qu'on fera pour pouvoir
remettre un peu les choses dans l'ordre
et faire que la population et la
majorité soit à l'écouté de la
population
c'est vraiment très important et il mais
je redirai donc fallait que les communes
ne sont pas des entités nitrates yves
paccaud ça ce sont d'abord des comptes
et de vie est pas traiter les sujets de
cet ordre là de cette façon là merci
serge pradines d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre du collectif citoyen de coignard
qui était opposé des coûts au projet de
rapprochement avec maurepas et on tient
aussi directeur général des services
akwaya merci à vous et bon week-end on
passe au résumé de l'actualité de la
semaine
à chaque rentrée son lot de nouveautés à
partir de septembre prochain le réseau
de bus s'étoffe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ski bus
proposera notamment des courses
supplémentaires certaines lignes seront
renforcés l'offre intensifier les
week-ends et le soir le point sur ces
évolutions avec un patrick jacques de
dixmude et marion tac pour la rentrée
2010 8,7 un tout nouveau réseau de bus
qu'accueillera le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines restructurer un
réseau parfois caduque
telle était la volonté de
l'agglomération nous allons commencer
dès le mois de février je crois 2016 à
travailler avec l'ensemble des douze
maires pour voir comment on pouvait
remettre à plat le réseau de bus voir ce
qui était pertinent voire les lignes qui
étaient grenelle beaucoup emprunté celle
qu'il était moi etc voilà deux tours m
sur la table via des questionnaires les
attend de trois mille usagers ont permis
l'amélioration du réseau certains tracés
ont été créés comme la ligne 8 qui
reliera la gare de villepreux les clés à
celle de plaisir gueugnon le réseau sera
également renforcée en soirée et le
week-end + 10 % de course lors de ces
périodes
nous n'avions pas beaucoup de bus le
week-end pas de le soir donc maintenant
nous allons avoir des bus 7 jours sur 7
jusqu'à minuit sur certaines lignes ce
qui n'existait pas y compris débute ce
dimanche
les itinéraires des bus se rééquilibre
pour permettre aux villes telles que
magny les hameaux de bénéficier plus
facilement du réseau de saint quentin
autre ambition augmenter les fréquences
et réduire le temps d'attenté aux heures
de pointe alors il a gardé l'idée
express alors les lignes express 700 des
lignes qui seront en voie en heure de
pointe tous les quarts d'heure et sinon
à la demi heure ça n'existait pas sur
nos sur nos lignes actuelles ou parfois
mais il fallait même attendre parfois
plus d'une heure pour voir plus pour
pour avoir un bus qui fait que
finalement au bout d'un certain temps
d'attentes les gens prennent leur
voiture en tout 2000 sans cours
supplémentaires par an seront réalisés à
partir du 3 septembre prochain afin de
faciliter encore plus le déplacement de
la population
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour
de l'actualité on dit avec lundi à 18h
sur l'antenne de tv2 78 et sachez que
atv 78 prendra ses quartiers à cannes la
semaine prochaine chaque jour dans nos
éditions
focus sur les yvelinois présent sur la
croisette ils sont nombreux premier
reportage du coup à suivre lundi à 18h
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]